it's finally happened after two years of
negotiations and almost 40 years of
being enemies Iran in the US and five
other world powers have signed a deal
that could mean big changes over here
and over there so what's the deal well
it gives foreign inspectors the right to
monitor Iran's nuclear program to make
sure it isn't developing a nuclear
weapon in exchange Iran will get some
sanctions lifted that means the Iranians
can look forward to easier access to
medicine food international banks and
other much-needed supplies this is a
huge step forward between the u.s. and
Iran who have been openly hostile ever
since the Iranian Revolution and the
hostage crisis in 1979 the u.s. wanted
to control Iran's influence so it
imposed sanctions and supported its
rivals like Iraq under Saddam Hussein
every US administration has classified
Iran as a state sponsor of terror and
former president george w bush even
included it in his axis of evil the
biggest source of this tension has been
Iran's nuclear program Iran's always
said it's for peaceful energy use but
the US and its allies suspected Iran was
trying to build a nuclear weapon but now
this deal offers an opportunity to move
in a new direction we should seize it so
who wouldn't be happy about this well a
long line of US Congress members Saudi
princes and Israeli politicians this is
a bad deal the worst possible outcome is
you've created a nuclear arms race in
the Mideast you put is well at risk and
you put us at risk the weirdest
reactions might be from Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu who said the
deal will allow Iran to take over the
entire world Netanyahu even started a
Twitter account in Farsi to try to
convince the Iranians not to sign the
deal right then there's Saudi the u.s.
is top Arab Ally and the richest and
most influential Arab country so long as
the US was keeping pressure on its
adversary Iran Saudi felt secure now
they worry a stronger Iran will reduce
Saudis influence in the region
so this is a done deal right pretty much
Congress will now debate it and
Republicans have vowed to block it but
President Obama has said he will veto
any vote
against the deal two years ago a phone
call between Obama and Iranian president
rouhani helped end the freeze between
the two countries now their challenge is
to convince the skeptics back home that
this deal is better for everyone